everyone is talking about inflation
inflation inflation
inflation it's the word that's been on
everyone's lips lately
and some are looking back at history in
fact we've not heard inflation talked
this much since really the 1970s
that's because over the past few months
prices for everything from gasoline to
groceries have been rising sharply
as the economy roars back from the
pandemic recession
this graph charts the consumer price
index
a metric that measures the average
change in prices for consumer goods and
services
compared to a year ago or more simply
put
inflation in may of this year prices
spiked five percent
to reach the highest annual inflation
rate in nearly 13 years
many economists believe that a small
amount of inflation around 2 percent
is inevitable and even desirable that's
essentially what we've had for the past
15 years
before this most recent surge but these
recent increases
have some fearing that the us might be
returning to the runaway inflation
of the 1970s no one wants to see that
um happen again so are we returning to
the spiraling inflation of the late
1960s
and 1970s or is today's inflation as the
fed assures us
transitory this is a extraordinarily
unusual time
for those old enough to remember it the
great inflation
was a period in which the cost of living
for millions of americans soared
from 1965 to 1982 prices for food and
everyday consumer items
rose dramatically from 2 in 1962
to 15 in 1979.
during that same period unemployment
also rose steadily
eventually reaching just above 10
percent the term
stagflation an economic condition of
both rising inflation
and increasing unemployment became the
go-to phrase to describe the period's
economic malaise this was a time
when consumers protested rising meat
prices
union members picketed for cost of
living pay increases
and long lines for unemployment and gas
became commonplace
here in new jersey ten percent of the
workforce is unemployed
across the nation the average is eight
percent the main lesson from the
seventies
is that kind of nagging persistent
recurrent double-digit inflation doesn't
happen overnight
it sets in over many years
and it's set in because of a long series
of policy mistakes
in washington great inflation
has its roots in the government spending
of the 1960s
consumer prices began rising under
president johnson
as he escalated the vietnam war and
launched his great society social
programs
but the double-digit inflation the
period is famous for didn't begin
until president richard nixon took
office the time has come
for a new economic policy for the united
states in 1971
nixon ordered that the dollar would no
longer be backed by gold
inflation robs every american every one
of you
nixon also influenced the fed's monetary
policy
pushing the central bank to pump more
money into the economy
and keep interest rates low by letting
inflation
rise gradually for a number of years
the the fed compromised
the trust the public health that the fed
would maintain price stability
businesses and households started
expecting that inflation would
persist as prices went up workers
started
pressing in part for unions as wages
went up
companies started raising prices even
more
and we got this game of leap fraud where
prices and wages both went up
we must whip inflation
right now these policy missteps
continued under president ford
and later under president carter the
issue was exacerbated further
by opec's oil embargoes a more serious
domestic problem that problem is
inflation
it wouldn't be until president jimmy
carter appointed paul volcker
as the chairman of the federal reserve
that the great inflation
finally began to disappear
paul volcker the fed chairman said i'm
going to stop
this cycle and he clamped down on the
growth of money supply and
jacked up interest rates it caused two
very severe recessions
but that it turned out to be really what
needed to happen to get inflation under
control
volcker's inflation crackdown
represented a new chapter for america's
monetary policy
the 1960s and 1970s the fed did not have
an articulated inflation targeting
strategy that inflation
should be around two percent and so they
were not focused
on um on keeping inflation under control
in the 1970s the fed was not even
willing
to commit to what they meant
by price stability those kind of trust
us trust that we will deliver
which is horrible policy
today we can see some clear similarities
between our modern inflationary period
and that of the 1970s
just like the 70s prices are rising the
federal reserve
has increased the money supply and
government spending is up
but comparing today's inflation with
that of the entire great inflation
especially the 1970s is not accurate i
graduated from college in 1975 i had a
front row seat
that nothing like that i i don't expect
anything like that to happen
today's inflation and the threat that we
have
is actually like the night the last half
of the 1960s
it's not like the 1970s in the mid 1960s
inflation had been running about 2
percent by the end of the 1960s
inflation went to about five percent
right the last inflation reading we had
was still below five percent
and so you're nowhere near 20 which was
the highest inflation reading at the end
of the 1970s
there's almost no period in the 1970s
that had his inflation as low
as we have now some of the recent
spikes in inflation are a very healthy
sign of the
of the recovery what we experienced last
year wasn't normal
take airfares in the airline industry
we have this dramatic drop of of
airfares that was a sign
of the risk that the whole industry
would collapse
it's a healthy sign that we see a
reversal of those increases
today for their part the fed says it
remains committed to its long-held
stance
that today's inflation is temporary the
fed believes that we're having a supply
shock
and so that's causing shortages and
temporary prices
that's the pet story what we're seeing
now we believe
is inflation in particular categories of
goods and services
that are being directly affected by this
unique historical event that none of us
has
lived through before called reopening
the economy after after closing it
every time we have an economic recovery
from a recession
we expect to see inflation rise above
two percent for a while
that's normal it turns out that these
impacts
are more than transitory if they're
lasting it persists
or even increase the fed might have to
do something to stop
on june 16th federal reserve officials
signaled that they expect to raise
interest rates
by late 2023 sooner than they
anticipated
in march